we have this tweet from Matthew Iglesias
and he asks an interesting question he
says I'm a very literal-minded person
but I don't understand the idea of a guy
currently losing the race for the GOP
Presidential nomination debating a
Democrat who isn't running I want to
pause real quick and say just because
descendants may be dropping in polls
doesn't mean he shouldn't be debating
anybody no I mean he's trying to win so
he's going to do this but it is an
interesting question of why Rhonda
Santos who's in second uh place is
debating a guy who's not running for
office so we have the the story here
from Politico DeSantis agrees to debate
Gavin Newsom on Fox News the California
governor has been trying to get his
Florida Republican counterparts to
engage on Wednesday he got it
okay so serious question why do you guys
think these guys are in a debate like
what's the point well I think you
mentioned it before the show I mean I
think they are both trying to gain
attention I think that they both would
ultimately like to be the people who are
facing off on the ticket I think if they
had done this at the height of kovid
when they both had such different
strategies it would be a really
interesting conversation for now it just
seems like their establishments are
trying to Rally around them and make it
seem like they are really the people in
charge especially interesting because
Joe Biden is the incumbent yeah this
strikes me as like a measuring contest
they're going to whip it out and see who
has a bigger GDP
whose State's bigger yeah actually
that's a good point I think that's
they're gonna do California is gonna
knew something's gonna be like in
California we do this and Ron's gonna be
like you got poop in the streets
everywhere I hope he does say that yeah
I really I think this would have been so
much more interesting if this was done
six months ago before DeSantis announced
that he was running for president yeah
because this is a legitimate debate how
California handled kovid versus how
Florida handled covet if you could have
two states that are like case studies
against each other it would be great
yeah and the American people really want
to know that and a critique of running
to Santa since he launched his campaign
is this is what he should have launched
his campaign on instead of attacking
Trump personally or having a surrogates
attack Trump he should have just
constantly been talking about what they
did during covet and people could make
the comparison for themselves without
feeling that he or his people were
attacking Trump so maybe this is his
attempt to reset his campaign since it
was kind of a slow rollout to to use a
kind word there so Santas I think is
just so bitter that Joe Biden is going
to be the nominee for 2024 he just can't
believe it or knew something yeah I
think newsom's going to be the Democrats
guy yeah this looks like this newsom's
coming out party this is like him
announcing he's going to run for
president basically why would he be
debating a vice a presidential candidate
and I said this last night and I'll say
it again the best possible scenario for
Democrats is Joe Biden at a rally Newsom
is there as a surrogate just in support
health issue affects Joe Biden panicked
in front of a crowd and in front of
Television Newsome runs full speed to
render first aid Panic ensue who's
Newsom then does the Press rounds of the
guy what was it like what was going
through rolling up his sleeves taking
the jacket off losing his tie and then
screaming for help and then putting on
every single television network what was
it like when you when you saved the
president's life that is the best case
scenario Democrats could have to get
this guy in the race I would also like
to I think that is the best case
scenario it makes me wonder As We Know
Joe Biden famously spends most of his
weekends almost all of them in Delaware
were one could maybe potentially get
secret medical treatment uh I wonder if
there will be I'm just gonna say I don't
know I'm just hyping uh it's just
hypothetical uh I wonder if sort of
along same lines we're gonna get an
announcement that tragically uh Joe
Biden has some sort of terminal illness
that won't allow him to continue so
though he wanted to we've got to have
someone else come forward and this will
place Newsome as the obvious Contender
it depends on how sneaky and capable you
think Democrats are because if Joe Biden
says I'm sick bro that's really damaging
for the Democrats as a brand they're
they're sickly leader and they were
forced to replace them Gavin news and
then then steps into The Fray as a
second tier Joe Biden nah it's not going
to fly Trump is winning in the polls and
even with the scenario described I do
not see a landslide possibility right
you'd think about going you go back in
time when the country is a bit more
cohesive a president having a heart
attack on stage and someone running out
and saving his life with CPR that guy's
gonna have an approval rating in the 80s
or 90s and he says something like I may
disagree we may be political Rivals but
we were all Americans and they're going
to be screaming even with something like
that Democrats would not be able to
muster Landslide level votes because
people are torn apart people hate the
Democrats but if the Democrat route is
Joe Biden is weak and Bows out
Trump wins
I I don't think you're wrong I'm just
saying it's probably again depending on
what they're they're able to Stage it's
probably simpler if they just say Joe
Biden has to exit he's not going to be
around they're super simple but failing
yeah like lose face if they did that I
think Newsom I just don't know what the
odds are like I said we gotta check the
calendar see when they're gonna appear
on stage together and all get prepared
to watch they do if they do
um I'm not saying it will happen I'm
just like
look if you were to ask me we talk about
January 6th that that video comes out
where the police chief is basically
saying someone may have wanted this
happen it's a cover-up January 6 was the
best thing for Democrats it's giving
them everything it's giving them the
Insurrection act to remove people from
office they got that guy Griffin I think
his name was removed from office they
they said oh he was an insurrectionist
now they're indicting Trump they are
they did the January 6 committees it may
not be as effective as they hope it is
but it is their weapon thinking in that
context I've said if Donald Trump did
not stop the riding on May 29th in DC
he'd still be president because the
narrative would be inverted
in that same context I'm thinking
forward what could the Democrats do that
would guarantee a victory or at least to
a certain degree rapidly accelerate
their possibility of winning and it's
Gavin Newsom on camera on every major
Network performing CPR and Joe Biden and
saving his life it also explains why he
was LeapFrog Kamal Harris there's one
exactly there's one and how they get Joe
by another race and Gavin in as the
front runner there's one Democrat who
doesn't want Joe Biden to bow out one
Jill now Joe Biden this is a quote from
Barack Obama in November of 2020. this
is what he said if I could make an
arrangement where I had a stand-in or a
front man or front woman to be president
and they had an earpiece in and I was
just in my basement in my sweats looking
through the stuff and I could sort of
deliver the lines while someone was
doing all the talking and ceremony I'd
be fine with that and Giovanni was like
I'm your man don't even worry about it
no they were like Joe Biden you're the
man but it doesn't have to be Joe Biden
oh no way that he would let Barack Obama
control him via an earpiece absolutely
he would Newsome is a lizard person I
mean that figuratively Media Matters is
calmed down he's going to be like tell
me whatever tell me tell me what to do
because he he's just a slimy guy who
wants power he didn't care I think
there's two different camps of Democrats
though there's like the Chicago the
corrupt Chicago people and then there's
the California people right like Nancy
Pelosi came from California politics
Schumer came from California politics
like
um these Newsome and Pelosi are like
indirectly related right am I totally
wrong are they I'm gonna double check
that I don't know I don't know I mean
not it wasn't Schumer it was
um Adam Schiff came from California not
not Schumer Schumer's in New York yeah
yeah
um there's like this this this
California breed of Democrats who are
very radical left and then there's the
Chicago breed and they're kind of in
competition with each other because they
both want to be the leaders of the
Democrats in Washington DC so I don't
think that he would listen to Barack
Obama the way the Biden would so like
the Clinton Obama Camp Biden all that is
that's like a unique kind of structure
within that system and then there's
other people like that's interesting
Newsome was his
uncle by marriage was Nancy Pelosi's
brother-in-law so they were at one point
very indirectly related I will say that
they do have a lot in common you know
they both uh didn't wear masks when they
instructed everyone else too yeah in
California they can do whatever they
want I will say I actually am super open
I I am critical of debates because I
feel like these big stage you know you
have six 12 candidates on where they
scream each other and try to get their
viral moments it's not effective we're
not learning anything about policy it's
it's whatever but I I think one-on-one
debates I mean you see this with culture
War can be really effective and having
Governors face off especially on issues
where their states in particular become
representations of cultural differences
that would be super cool like I would
love to see the governor of Washington
debate the governor of Idaho on the
abortion travel law right there are
things that could be good about this
format I'm just saying right now this is
obviously playing into the presidential
candidate as opposed to the welfare of
their states there are two factions in
this country
that we here at timcast are unable to
book and it is
prominent leftist personalities and the
DeSantis campaign
I had someone tell me that they don't
want to come on IRL uh someone who's for
to Santa say well you know irl's two
pro-trump so it's not even worth going
on but I feel like it is worth coming on
to at least talk about it but they're
it's so weird I feel like they're
walking into a hostile environment we
had we had Lance from the Surfs and vosh
come on this show you know we had uh uh
uh Emma from the majority report come on
the show but it's it's what would you
ask them if they came on the show we
would have any descended supporter on
the show the same as what we're having
you on the show and we would talk about
the exact same things but they've
explicitly said they won't have people
on the show and so we're actually
supposed to have a big culture War uh
show not this week next week debating
between two supporters of DeSantis uh
DeSantis support on a trump supporter
and The Descent supporter just said he
wants to back out because he's now back
in Trump and we were trying to get
someone from the sentences campaign we
can't do it yeah because I think that's
actually what they won't I feel like you
want in particular but you know to have
a variety of opinions that's actually
better we I think you never really want
to be a part of the echo chamber and
that's why you need to have people from
both sides it's interesting that they
are it is choosing even though the
invitation is open it is it is funny
that we're it's easier for us to get
leftists than it is to get the Santa
supporters you got to say they'll do it
to be fair to people hey John cardillo
on the show right so it's not like we
don't get any of course and he and he
stated this case the weird part is I
can't tell the difference between
cardillo and anybody else like I don't
care the pilot I really don't mind the
politics you know I would love to debate
Marxism with the Marxist I want to know
more about it like tell me yeah I think
that's the thing you want to have more
information and especially like if you
had someone who was on the the Santa's
campaign here we could ask more specific
questions about what's going on and they
could answer them yeah I'm a manifest so
if we start manifesting they will come
on we might so what we're thinking for
the next uh tomorrow we have Alex Stein
and Modine coming on
are they going to fight right here at
this table I know but uh I don't even I
don't know let's see what happens with
the show but then the next week the
question was do we ask the former Trump
former DeSantis supporter now Trump
supporter to just bow out and we'll find
someone who's backing DeSantis or do we
actually just keep the booking as it is
and then hear the arguments as to why he
no longer does and why he did it's tough
because there's there are a few people
we could I could probably reach out to
John Cardell and ask him if he wants to
come on and debate protestantis uh I
think Kurt schlichter might be a decent
supporter I'm not entirely sure there's
a handful that are that are you know in
the bag for uh uh in the corner for
DeSantis I don't know what do you guys
think should we
just keep it as it is and hear why this
guy no longer supports DeSantis or
should we try and get somebody else I
think cardillo will be interesting just
because he was so gung-ho I wonder if he
still as gung-ho as he was in the past
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna say who it
is
yeah well I'll I'll I won't I won't say
who the person is who's no longer
backing to sandusk because that's their
private business to announce but Laura
Loomer will be coming on and then we are
looking for someone who was a disanta
supporter so I I feel like it would be
interesting to hear this person's
perspective of why they were for santis
and then change in terms of a debate
like to keep that Spirit of culture War
alive I do feel like you have to find
someone yeah from the DeSantis camp and
like well they won't do it well the
question is like I agree you've had a
lot of people on like maybe there are
stances people who have been on the show
before who would be willing to do it if
Johnson maybe thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time